what we're gonna do in this top left
hand corner is put in an exponential but
it doesn't have a as the base it's gonna
have some other number I've just called
it a on your keyboard you can actually
type a and then if you go to the
character above the number six I believe
it's called a hat
this guy here if you type in a and type
the Hat you should see your cursor goes
up to the top to make a power and then
you just type in X and then you should
get a to the power of X if you've done
it right and if I'm predicting it
properly and will then ask you would
you'd like to add a slider go ahead and
do that and you'll get a slider like
mine so just type this if you just type
this I mean you can get to it on the
desmos keyboard but this is I'm just
lazy and don't like using my mouse so
this will get you there straight with
the keyboard okay now I did you might
notice i did adjust the boundaries of my
slider you don't have to do that but you
can see i'm gonna play around with some
numbers in here between 1 and 5 okay in
fact I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
animate it because I'm lazy now I want
you to remember huh there we go these
are the exponential curves that we had a
look at earlier and we noticed something
weird and interesting about the
exponential curve and its gradient do
you remember that the grading of an
exponential curve no matter which
exponential curve you've got right it
starts down low it's very shallow over
there and then it becomes very high
because this part of the curve is really
steep
yeah steep gradient means a really large
positive gradient and it is positive why
is it always positive X is greater than
zero but importantly it also never turns
around to become less than that it never
sort of becomes a decreasing function do
you remember that language okay so what
you've got and you can if you're
animating let me just hit pause write
what you've got to see was that if you
take the derivative of that function and
let me to pop that into decimals as well
if you don't want to type that in you
can actually just go down to your bottom
right hand corner of your keyboard and
under functions over there if you go to
miscellaneous sorry you can't see it all
the best here because right on the edge
of my thing if you're going under
miscellaneous
Dion DX should be right there near the
bottom right hand corner so that means
differentiate whatever you're about to
type and you can just type in D / DX and
you'll get this okay I think it said G C
D which is greatest common devisor but
it's closed it's closed and the
resolution is not the best so I don't
blame you that's okay and then put in
your original function a to the X right
now I'm just going to put mine back in
now let's just hit play on this right so
what do you remember does this jog your
memory do you remember thinking about
this right now hopefully you notice
there's that special point when the
green and the red graphs cross do you
see that in fact then it just crossed
they become the same graph yeah do you
remember what that spot was it's when a
it's when your base equals what exactly
e right 2.71 bla bla bla and if you like
you can find it just like we did before
I'll just put it back to stubby fingers
don't fail me now
and we get roughly there you go that's
pretty close so this is sort of when
they're bang on right you remember that
okay now what I'm really interested in
is like we fixated on that and then we
got a result for it but what I'm really
interested is when they're not actually
the same right so here my derivative the
green graph is above my actual graph
okay and if I make a less than 2.718
like so whoops if I slide it across so
something like that
our green grass below now what I want
you to notice is it's an exponential
curve but it's like a smaller version of
that right I want to work out what
difference there is what it's a kind of
exponential but what exponential
specifically okay so what I want you to
do now is you can go ahead and hire that
or just pop your lid down because you
won't need it in this next bit and if
you haven't already make this heading
it's the 16th of December
yeah I can hardly believe in no what
we're gonna do is we are going to
differentiate this exponential with
another base right like for example if
it wasn't if it was two or if it was ten
or a hundred or something like that
right now in order to do this we need to
actually use the skill that I was
reviewing with you earlier which is
changing back and forth between
Exponential's and logs we're gonna do
this and work out and it's gonna seem a
little bit of a weird place to start but
I want us to work out what this thing is
equal to this thing here this result
that we're about to prove we're gonna
use it as we do this derivative trying
to have a question yeah yeah okay all
right now at the moment I'm saying e ^
whatever this stuff is and K can be any
number just like over here K changed
value all the time what does this equal
to right now I could put a question mark
here because I don't know what it's
equal to yet but let's use algebra let's
just put a letter on that let's just
call this guy X okay what I want to do
is find out what's X actually equal to
do you know the answer or do you want to
suggest where we can go because I don't
want the answer just yet okay yeah give
me a suggestion where how could I
simplify this and start working with it
[Music]
are you
are you changing base up here is that
where you're trying to do okay so let's
think about base for a second I'll come
to your suggestion in a minute
um Sophie I have a base from this Ln
right what is the base below it's a so
I'll just write this in full form it's
actually going to be helpful to us now I
don't need to change this to a base of
it because it already is so I'll just
leave that as it is but I want to do
something else that might help me
simplify this do you do you have an idea
Sophie or I'll take anything
oh yeah I know what you mean yeah I like
so I could have written
2.718 etc right I think the word you're
looking for is constant as opposed to
variable yeah like it's a number that
just stays put the short answer is yes
that K could be anything we like and
that X is what we're about to find out
what it is so I don't know what it is
yet that's what we're trying to do okay
so what we're going to try and do this
is your suggestion is to take this this
is currently an exponential equation
right something to the power of
something else and we can rewrite it
we've just been doing it over here we
can rewrite it as a log equation I think
we can do that okay so think about how
we rearrange this right if you like have
a look at how you did question one have
a look at how you did question one
that's exactly what we're gonna do here
except I don't have three I've got a I
don't have a hundred I've got X I'm just
gonna rearrange okay
so what would the new subject be look
carefully what became the subject over
there in this case we made K the subject
remember that it was the power the power
became the new subject what's the power
here it's that guy are you okay with
that that's gonna become the subject
let's write that all down like so that's
becoming the subject and then everything
else rearranges on the right hand side
right what does it become it'll become
log and then the base moves over into
the base in fact I'm even gonna draw
that like so the base becomes the base
and there's only one number left to
write the only number I have written
which is X now hold on a second yeah
wait wait a second right look at this
the left-hand side and the right-hand
side of the equation look very very
similar right you've got logs you got
the same base and then you just got
these two numbers which look different
but they can't be different if they're
equal right like that's what the equal
sign means
so we're concluding here that this
mystery number we're trying to work out
not X its equal to okay all right and
what this means is put a big box around
this because we're about
to use it aid to the power of log K
equals K that's what it equals okay
and if you want just grab your
calculator there and just blow a bit and
choose a number and go e put it into
your calculator ^ and then in the power
put log of what do you want to nine pi
there 18 okay and what do you get as
you're out on yes right yep from this
line to this line okay
it was tricky to go from this line to
this line it's the definition of a log
it's the same way we rearrange this
equation so I want you to go back to
your first question you did today and
stare really harder that's basically the
way we did by definition so this one
here it became this right there there it
is right there okay I know there's a lot
of things that look very similar okay
but that's sort of the point so that we
get to this result okay all right